bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo ios o cavolo ma sono stupido la
mia camera bellissimo armadio
come posso stare senza di lui da tutti
ragazzi vedere questo video sono poi
genio oggi siamo tornati su una noi rate
non l'ho mai fatto ma top ma arrivato il
momento
ve lo spiego su amazon si vendono tante
cose utili che voi prendete tutti i
giorni mi è compreso compreso cibo
perché io non esco di casa sono pigro
vabbè dai neo attendono sull'amazon
anche cose inutili completamente e oggi
faremo una bellissima top delle 20 cose
più inutili ma anche belle che vengono
su amazon
cominciamo numero 20
alla posizione numero 20 ragazzi
troviamo 7 di circo e mani per le dita
nel senso che ti dà cinquemani che tu
puoi mettere sulle dita e fare perché
esiste questa no questa è la posizione
ovvero 20 c quindi noi neanche la cosa
peggiore che vedrete prove sono contento
perché la gente compra queste robe qui
si fa la recensione mi sembra giusto
perché perché dovresti comprare questa
cosa e fare questo al tuo gatto per
quale motivo è la posizione proventi non
ha un senso ma neanche le altre immagini
premio numero 19 al gore 19 troviamo fa
ninos pencil shatner che vuol dire
temperino per a forma di naso e un
temperino to infili la matita nel naso i
giri io sono sempre più incredulo di
come la gente passi la propria vita io
non ho mai capito niente
posizione numero 18
alla posizione numero 18 troviamo the
original natural che tua in the moscato
moscatt io mia vorrei alzarmi ma sono
molto comodo e sto seduto ma l'avrei
fatto del vino per gatti io non so cosa
dire ragazze bologna intanto non ci
hanno finito le scorte
wow numbers e benji alla posizione delle
ore 17 troviamo un cuscino di nicolas
cage perché mica giustamente nicolas
cage fa i cuscini che scompaiono e poi
ricompare la faccia di nicolas cage
questo qua costa non ti dice il prezzo
che non volevo saperlo né aber sexy
fecero 16 abbiamo un porta palle da golf
non quello che per anche se la forma
sembra quello da golf ice le palle da
golf dell'infinita dentro andiamo avanti
ma 15
alla posizione numero 15 abbiamo un bel
maschione perché con soli 34 dollari vi
portate a casa il fidanzato cuscino
ideale per le relazioni sentimentali a
breve termine soprattutto se dovete
dormire e volete della compagnia che
normalmente non avreste come vedete
potete abbracciare il vostro ragazzo di
cuscino io abbracciare volentieri lei
però facciamo facciamo che non tutti
hanno questa fortuna beato stock uscì in
34 dollari
no paura del genere umano 2 14 alla
posizione numero cattolici abbiamo un
gigantesco e non sto scherzando serpente
di gomma serpente di gomma gigante
proprio di quelli di questi gli orsetti
che mangiate però un serpente di gomma
io non so come sia possibile otto piedi
di sapiente il 27 libri a 12 giri di 12
chili 120 dollari
io sto male come è possibile spiegami
come fai a mangiarti un serpente di pt
12 chili come ma neanche un po avere o
pesa così tanto 13 come anna veic
al numero 14 per soli 25 dollari ragazzi
troviamo una lingua di gomma per esseri
umani per questo momento di essere
marito che puoi leccare il tuo gatto c'è
il senso col cane anche se tu il tuo
animale domestico tu metti questa roba
eletti io non so
a volte mi fermo e penso ma la mia
ragazza non poteva far così andiamo
number two of troviamo la face ben
coin.it insegne bank altro vari money
saving che sarebbe salvadanaio krypi
senso io non potrei mai avere questo
salvadanaio metterci delle monete senza
aver paura che di notte mi fissi perché
questo fa nuove l'aborto non so che dire
devo orribile cioè aprile muove la bocca
e la free quando ti avvicinate la moneta
io non so paura di vivere 14 dollari
fantastico 11 come il ranger games avete
presente il vostro cane avete presente
quando piscia per terra ok avete
presente quando piscia per terra e non
capite dove ha pisciato sentite solo le
calze appiccicose per terra perché
sapete capisce che parte che vi si
appiccica la casta che schifo non vedete
l'ora pisciato benissimo punturine
detector live raggi ultravioletti per
evidenziare la pipì del vostro cane
gatto che per terra vi evidenzia tutto
ma neanche sherlock holmes trova gli
indizi così 10 dollari questa roba è
veramente utile a comprare subito top
ten ragazzi the farting animals coloring
book allora nel 2016 uscito questo libro
incredibile che è un libro per animali
che furono che puoi colorare e non solo
number one best seller cioè è stato
vendutissimo soli 5 dollari poi colorare
animali che scorrevano questo è
veramente fantastico voglio delle foto
di repertorio grazie eccolo qua perfetto
ragazzi io mio figlio compreso questo
bravo con quei colori meglio di me brava
bambina come fossero gli animali se
scoraggiassero questo è una bruna
troviamo questo poncho il poncho ragazzi
una cosa che serve per quando piove
promettete addosso non vi si bagnano i
vestiti mettete anche il cappuccio non
vi bagnate la testa ma questo porto è
diverso perché questo pocho ma anche i
sacchetti per la pipì e per la pop
cioè nel senso voi mettete sto poncho e
vi mettete i sacchetti così a dati in
giro non vi calate mango lebbra pisciate
cagate è tutto lì tutto dentro al pocho
poi impacchettate il poncho via numero
foto actis holder cioè il gatto che dal
deretano tipo uscire i fazzoletti ti
riprendi deciso il naso a soli 32
dollari e 99 senza abbiamo questo gatto
incredibile la 91 nascondi dentro cosa
cioè noi che glielo infine che altro
dentro c'è anche un video dimostrativo
vediamolo subito guarda guarda che lui
non capisce perché giustamente diceva di
esseri umani che cosa stronca che si
inventano tutti i giorni io vi immagino
un gatto perfetto era la lettera la mia
immaginazione perfetto era esattamente
colori stavo pensando bellissimo
bellissimo il mondo è un posto
meraviglioso nablus e ben
così all allora questa cosa voi la
vedete di te ma cos'è
ve lo spiego porcospino c slater
praticamente voi presenterà la grattugia
per il formaggio perfetto a forma di
porcospino posizione numero 6 il kama
potrà che non è quello che pensate voi è
meglio perché esistono le posizioni per
fare la cacca a soli 5 c'è anche
all'azione king che costa di più di
quella in carta perché quelli in cassa
la potresti usare volevo dirti culo
fantastico vedo che la gente che la vita
è contenta e quindi siamo contenti anche
noi
posizione numero 5 ghiaccio per
americani fantastico dove di questa roba
dentro il porta ghiaccio e ti crea dei
proiettili grossi così veramente nuovo
numero faccio sopracciglia al led c'è
nel senso tu metti sta roba metti la
metti e soprattutto ma io non so cosa
dire numero tre signori glass flip flops
a soli 19 dollari 99 macchie dico devi
togliere il 16 per 116 89
abbiamo le ciabatte con l'erba sintetica
io voglio questa roba subito cosa serve
a mettere le ciabatte in giardino niente
tanto ci avete le ciabatte col giardino
dentro incorporato fantastico bellissimo
le voglio subito stato che poco quindi
fantastico la gente l'uso in spiaggia
ovunque non in giardino bellissimo
al secondo posto troviamo attenzione
questa prova potrebbe farmi morire di
crepacuore ma la mettiamo lo stesso un
millepiedi telecomandato perché esistono
a quanto pare dei mille piedi telefoni
cellulari telecomando non calava chinino
eretico mani il millepiedi che schifo
cioè io praticamente devo avere sta roba
che gira per casa madonna che c'è
un'opera che sono gratis purtroppo ogni
tanto a noi ha il coraggio di recessiva
sono stati solo 20 minuti di
funzionamento ma ragazzi che 20
ma ben ragazzi siamo giunti all'ultima
posizione questo io vi giuro che lo
compro freezer boy è un adesivo che tu
puoi mettere sul frigo per rendere il
tuo frigo kemboi extralarge signori
questo è mio
subito subiti 19 regalato ma che roba
incredibile e tra l'altro tra i runner
non basta questo non ho tra l'altro due
tirano la prendi il pennarello
cancellabile tu scrivi sui gem boy
bellissimo lo voglio immediate al tratto
amazon joyce questo incredibile spero me
lo vendono in italia
sì mi arriva all 8 agosto fantasti
questo video registrato molto tempo fa
ragazza mi arriva indietro nel tempo
no è che sarà partito breva cazzo e
quindi ho registrato un po di video
prima però spero che mi sia arrivato
perché merita lo voglio subito signori
pare vi sia piaciuto io sono molto
soddisfatto di questi episodi fatemi
sapere se volete altre top ten di
qualcos'altro che vedono nei commenti e
ci penso io come sempre iscrivetevi al
canale schiacciata anche quella
bellissima campanellina vestiti perché
quella campanellina vi fa arrivare alle
notifiche se faccio uscire un video che
sono mi arriva la notifica quindi come
se non vi scrive sti come se non fossi
iscritti schiacciato dalla campanellina
maledetta e noi signori ci vediamo come
sempre ad un prossimo video dei ragazzi
[Musica]